[Musique]
en développement constant le port de
marseille vient de voir ses exportations
pour la seule afrique du nord
atteindre le chiffre record de 3
millions de tonnes cependant ce chiffre
risque demain d'être amputé de deux
millions de top car une menace plane sur
tous ceux qui travaillent pour
l'exportation
demain un sur huit de ces travailleurs
peut devenir un chômeur et à l'intérieur
de l'entreprise
ce serait le licenciement pur et simple
de ces spécialistes à qui l'avenir ne
semblait poser aucun problème
demain l'industrie automobile devrait
déboucher dix mille ouvriers
si le quart des voitures destinées à
l'exportation de murray sur le quai de
départ
condamnant du même coup autant
d'accessoires à rester dans les stocks
du magazine
demain toutes ces raffineries qui
transforment le pétrole brut on pourrait
se trouver privés de 40 % de leur volume
d'exportation et demain peut-être la
moitié de ses vannes se fermerait avec
un manque à gagner de 13 milliards de
francs pour l'industrie du pétrole
demain l'industrie sucrière verrait en
plus de ses difficultés actuelles
la moitié du sucre exporté restés
invendus pertes 12 milliards cette
lourde menace est pour demain la france
isolée de son prolongement algérien son
principal client connaîtrait une crise
grave
cette crise s'étendre est partout déjà
éprouvé par la perte du marché
indochinois l'industrie textile vers et
15 milliards de commandes annulées et
l'arrêt d'une partie de ces métiers
ce serait 5000 ouvriers sans emploi dans
le nord 7000 dans l'est 15 cents dans la
seule ville de roanne l'industrie
électronique en pleine expansion verrait
son élan brisé car l'algérie représente
7 milliards de francs d'achats du jour
au lendemain
le tiers des appareils produit irait
grossir le stock des invendus le trafic
avec l'algérie représente pour le seul
port de marseille 2 millions 500 mille
tonnes 2 millions 500 mille tonnes en
moins on peut aisément en imaginer les
suites
il ya plus grave le pétrole saharien est
la plus grande chance pour la france de
redevenir une grande puissance déjà
coincé entre deux pays indépendants le
pétrole saharien perdait le seul
débouché demeurait sous le contrôle de
la france il ya plus grave encore sur
huit travailleurs de l'exportation avoir
un chômeur c'est à voir chaque jour une
heure de travail en moins c'est donc de
l'argent en moins pour les laboratoires
de recherche pour les bureaux d'études
sans lesquelles aucun progrès technique
n'est possible car qui dit stagnation
dit régression et une réussite technique
comme la caravelle qui représente dix
ans d'études et des centaines de
millions d'investissements est
impensable dans un pays privé de moyens
techniques
de plus la disparition de l'algérie clé
de voûte de l'édifice africain
entraînerait la dislocation de l'union
française
le standard de vie des français
n'échapperait pas aux conséquences de
cet effondrement
ce serait des jours de vacances en moins
ce serait les facilités en moins ce
serait des plaisirs en moins
tous
être ou ne pas être une grande nation
telle est la question
la france mérite mieux que de se
résigner à la retraite elle a mieux à
faire que de vivre sur sa grandeur
passée de souvenirs et de recettes
gastronomiques attention à demain
pensez-y
[Musique]